الحظ والحظ فقط هو الذي يمنع وقوعا انفجار
نووي في محطه باوكرانيا لكن تجنب حادث
نووي ممكن وفق مبادئ اعلنها المدير العام
للوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه رافاييل
جراسي طلب بعدم شن هجوم مهما كان نوعه من
المحطه او عليها وبعدم استخدام الموقع
لتخزين اسلحه او عسكريين او عدم فصلها عن
شبكه الكهرباء المحليه محطه النوويه هي
الاكبر في اوروبا وتعرضت سابقا لعمليات
استهداف بشكل متكرر وقطعها عن شبكه
الكهرباء سبعه مرات تم منذ استيلاء الجيش
الروسي عليها بعد ايام من بدايه الحرب في
اوكرانيا مبادئ الوكاله الدوليه حظيت
بتوافق اوكرانيا روسي خلال جلسه لمجلس
الامن الدولي السفير الروسيه فاسيلين قال
ان مقترحات تتماشى مع الاجراءات الروسيه
القائمه بالفعل المحطه معتبرا ان اي تهديد
للمحطه هو من كياف والغرب بالمقابل قال
السفير الاوكرانيه
ان مبادئ المدير العام لضمان سلامه محطه
زابوريا تنطبق على جميع محطات توليد
الطاقه في العالم داعيا لنزع السلاح من
المنطقه وانهاء ما وصفه بالاحتلال الروسي
للمحطه المدير العام للوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه رافايا الجروس يعتبر ان
الاهم هو الحد الادنى المشترك والذي قال
انه حظي بتاييد واسع النطاق ولم يعارضه اي
صوت قام بزياره المحطه نهايه مارس الماضي
وهو يكفر منذ ذلك الحين جهوده محذرا من
خطر حقيقي لوقوع حادث نووي لمتابعه المزيد
نصل الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب
الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات